Alcohol is the second leading cause of premature death in the United States.
Excessive alcohol use is associated with brain tissue loss and intellectual
impairments.
&gt;&gt; Long term alcohol use also results in problems with the liver including fatty
liver and cirrhosis of the liver.
&gt;&gt; In addition to heart attack, heart disease, hypertension, stroke, cancer and
impaired immunities which are all associated with excessive long term alcohol
use.
&gt;&gt; That's a lot of negative effects so keep that in mind. Now, let's recap the
benzodiazapines and the barbituates. Both of those are used as medicines, but
they're also both abused. The barbiturates are used as medicine to treat
epilepsy, because they reduce seizure activity. And the benzodiazepines are
used to treat anxiety, and sometimes they're prescribed for individuals as a
sleep aide for those with insomnia.